[Musique]
bruno retailleau bonjour bonjour jean
jacques bourdin vous êtes sénateur les
républicains de la vendée et vous allez
être déposé une proposition de loi pour
interdire les listes communautariste aux
prochaines élections aux élections
globalement et aux prochaines
municipales
quand allez-vous déposé cette
proposition de loi la semaine prochaine
la semaine prochaine pourquoi pourquoi
c'est du vent j'ai entendu thierry
mariani votre ancien collègue et aux
républicains nous dire mais c'est du
vent ah non mais ça le rassemblement
national
oui il ne veut surtout pas qu'on règle
les problèmes plus on aura de problème
en france pour le rassemblement national
plus ce parti prospérera non ce que je
constate moi c'est qu'il y ait un islam
politique en france qui est en train de
construire une contre-société à visées
séparatistes et je pense que le conseil
sous nos yeux il y en a de multiples
preuves et si on ne réagit pas si on ne
pose pas des limites républicaine alors
vous verrez demain on aura des têtes de
liste qui pourrait s'emparer de villes
en france
pas aujourd'hui aux élections
européennes ya des listes qui ont fait
dans une cinquantaine de bureaux de vote
plus de 10% ou bien moi comme d'autres
d'ailleurs parce que ça c'est trans
partisans j'entendais l'autre jour je
crois que c'était chez vous un gérald
darmanin qu'il connaît bien le problème
qui a fait des propositions sébastien
lecornu et d'autres encore donc moi je
pense que cette question là elle est
grave parce que elle nous concerne elle
concerne la république quelle république
quel modèle de société on veut est-ce
qu'on veut toujours la laïcité en france
et le problème des grains dans la mesure
où ils s'étalent sous nos yeux
comment s'est-elle tignes a parlé de
l'union des démocrates musulmans
français c'est bien là que deux agents
n'a que 2 mai mais c'est bien sûr bien
sûr aujourd'hui
mais aujourd'hui politique ce qui est
encore qui se disent non en mai le frère
ed se disent qu'ils ne sont pas nés le
phénomène de radicalisation de l'islam
il est massif je vous en donne des
en mai je vais vous en donner des
exemples deux études alors l'institut
montaigne à deux ans 27 ou 28 % de nos
compatriotes musulmans qui place la
charia la loi roudy je sus des lois de
la au dessus de la loire public tout
récemment la fondation jean jaurès
l'ifop jérôme fourquet nous apprend que
27% même chose vos collègues consoeurs
la communauté ce fameux livre sur trappe
qui est le lieu en europe qui a envoyé
le plus jihadistes se battre au levant
la confidence du président françois
hollande qui parlait d'une possible
partition de la france car si ça ne vous
suffit pas moi ça me suffit moi je suis
un législateur je tiens la république la
république c'est une chose commune et je
ne veux pas qu'elle soit détricoté par
les mener des frérots salafistes les
choses sont absolument claires et je me
battrai avec toutes les armes que j'ai à
ma disposition qui sont déjà
législatives
c'est le cas pour les le voile par
exemple dans les sorties scolaires c'est
le cas pour interdire le financement de
partis politiques qui seraient
communautarisme pour interdire des
candidatures des professions de foi qui
professerait oui mais beaucoup disent
c'est impossible parce que par exemple
je prends l'exemple il ya deux parties
l'union des démocrates musulmans
français qui veut présenter j'avais tout
à l'heure son fondateur qui veut
présenter une cinquantaine de liste en
france à peu près il y a aussi notre
parti qui s'appelle parti égalité
justice qui s'adresse à la communauté
franco turque
bon ces deux parties comment pouvez-vous
les interdire comment avez vous pouvez
vous les qualifier de communautarisme
quand on me dit que parce qu'il
s'appelle jeanne goerrian attendez
attendez parce qu'il s'appelle l'union
des démocrates musulmans français mais
le mot n'a rien à voir c'est là visées
sécessionnistes
moi on m'a dit la même chose je me
souviens vous savez gérer parlementaire
oui avant la loi sur la burqa en 2010
y'avait le niqab le niqab la burqa le
voile intégral le voile intégral est
bien y avait des mines un spécialiste
constitutionnalistes qui nous expliquer
mais c'est pas possible sur otayo
comment vous pouvez dans l'espace public
interdire une mode vestimentaire est ta
soeur on l'a fait le conseil
constitutionnel décoratifs léo comment
comment fait-on qu'est ce que le
communautarisme d'abord est ce que la
loi de la république n'est pas
suffisante aujourd'hui non non non si
elle est appliquée fermement fermement
elle n'est pas suffisant elle ne l'est
pas elle ne l'est pas il faut justement
que la règle soit clair parce que on est
testée par cet islam politique
conquérant qu'est ce que l'islam
politique moi je ne confonds pas avec un
islam apaisé
lui il a sa place dans la république
l'islam politique c'est celui qui
placent au dessus du lot de la loi de la
république la loi religieuse et bien moi
les choses sont claires le
communautarisme c'est une forme de
sécession avec la république qui
consiste à privilégier une partie de la
population a raison de son appartenance
ethnique ou religieuse
le bien nous avons les outils il n'y a
pas que le communautarisme musulman mais
communautariser les réseaux c'est ce qui
construit la société française
malheureusement ou heureusement non non
non non non non parce que vous avez un
modèle et vous ça sur ses modèles
anglo-saxons le mode vous avez
totalement raison
le modèle anglo saxon qui se répand et
là vous avez vraiment je pense que vous
faites un constat qui est juste dans le
monde et à ce modèle anglo saxon nous
sommes nous devrions être ils sont aux
etats unis une sorte d' archipel qui
juxtapose des comics des communautés les
unes par rapport aux autres
y'a pas de laïcité c'est à dire que une
société communautariste c'est la
juxtaposition de croyances nous c'est la
laïcité
la laïcité c'est quoi c'est la
neutralité la république demande pas aux
français de ne pas croire ou de croire
la république exige du citoyen ou plutôt
de l'homme privé que dans l'ordre public
il abandonne ses croyances parce que la
laïcité c'est la concorde civile c'est
ce qui permet aux jeunes
demain de refuser le voile oui c'était
mon psy batteur oui le voile c'est un
marquage de 7 à marc h maxi société il
existe aussi un parti chrétien démocrate
on ne voit pas l'intérêt
mais il ya une grosse différence bloqué
parce que le parti démocrate chrétien
s'adresse non pas des intérêts chrétiens
pour les chrétiens il s'intéresse à tous
les officiels il défend quoi le mythique
rétine et il s'adresse à tous les
français comme la cftc
l'idée méthodes la cftc le sait c'est
pour dire chrétien réfère défend tous
les ouvriers tous les travailleurs
ils peuvent être d'inspiration
chrétienne mais c'est très différent
la grande différence j'entendais des
commentateurs qui ont oublié souvent
leur culture historique
les démocrates chrétiens en france ou en
europe
mais la cdo en allemagne où la cdo en
allemagne jamais ils n'ont posé comme
principe que la loi religieuse devait
surpasser la loi civile parce qu'il ya
le fameux mur injonction rang des mondes
la césar ce qui est à tout le monde va
vous rouge donc c'est une fausse cette
info parlant aleris l'union des
démocrates musulmans français placent la
loi religieuse au dessus des lois de la
république et bien scellier gawlik as tu
es bien doute et il faut voir justement
c'est ce que je propose dans mon texte
il fera regarder sur par exemple les
professions de foi ce qui est dit ce qui
n'est pas dit il fera regarder si les
femmes sont voilées ou non parce que le
voile pour moi c'est pas seulement un
bout de tissu
le voile et zineb el rhazoui le dit très
bien c'est pas seulement aboutissent us
et un marquage à visées séparatistes
il s'agit dans l'espace public de dire
on est on appartient à une catégorie de
français seulement et sexiste le voile
c'est quand même le signe de la solution
car nathan détient une le voile le voile
qui quand d'une religieuse appartient à
la france moi j'arrive à l'annuler vous
mais moi aussi mais et le reste d'un
cancer de la vénerie retailleau oui on
est bien d'accord mais c'est cet insigne
religieux le voile c'est hachette
politico religieux non le coran mariam
barre des 6 en attendant les yeux dans
leur rue
il y étudie l'islam nous a prêté pendant
très longtemps très longtemps le monde
musulman s'est passé de voile on cite
par exemple cette anecdote de nasser en
54 ans 55 qui fait un discours ai dit
vous rendez compte ce que nous ont
demandé les frères musulmans il voudrait
que nos femmes et nos filles soient
voilées et là la foule
s'esclaffe de rire qu'est ce qui se
passe en iran aujourd'hui vous avez un
pote et d'un mouvement de protestation
des femmes qui enlèvent leur voile le
voile c'est le signe d'une soumission de
la femme par rapport à l'homme
eh bien je ne veux pas demain que du
jeune française soit contrainte de
porter dans certains quartiers le voile
alors est ce que les hommes et les
obligeait du port du voile dans l'espace
public pour le demander ou le niqab
oui le voile dans l'espace public je
pense qu'il contrevient aux règles moi
je vous le voulez non mais non je lui
demande
- lou le jeu le demande dans les sorties
scolaires je le demande dans l'exercice
de leur mandat par le public non et
pourquoi plus que la kippa pourquoi
parce que je pense qu'on ne peut pas le
faire en matière constitutionnelle par
contre on a des outils pour le faire
pour les élus et notamment pour les
sorties scolaires
il faut le faire là où la république
doit demeurer dans l'ordre public
voilà c'est ça la république il a l'oeil
rivé il ya le citoyen déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen article
10 que je rappelle nul ne doit être
inquiété pour ses opinions même
religieuses pourvu que leur
manifestation ne trouble pas l'ordre
public établi par la loi mais voilà
absolument absolument l'article en
quatre donc la rhune froid
une femme qui se promène dans la rue
avec un foulard ou un voile ne trouble
pas l'ordre public avec une burqa ci est
ce que je constate qu'une bourse ya sept
en liga n'étant pratiquement pas envie
le loonie qu'un cave le new camus est
même chose et pour la même chose sa
semelle une affaire privée mais
il a redit mais elle se tournèrent
barret ne sont pas verbalisés
donc ce que je propose moi c'est que en
cas de récidive les choses sont claires
on supprime les aides sociales
voilà en cas de récidive quand on porte
voix d'une femme qui porte le voile
intégral les choses au clair sur les
allocations familiales sur les cet islam
politique nous teste en permanence donc
est ce que la république doit renoncer
fermeté fermeté la main ne doit pas
trembler intransigeance même la laïcité
grande barrière contre le poison du
fanatisme c'est robert badinter qui n'a
absolument pas celle du genre j'ai
côtoyé au sénat et des trois sénateurs
je l'entends dû récemment exprimé son
avis sur le voile dans les sorties
scolaires j'ai lu aussi ce qu'elles
créent elisabeth badinter qu'est ce
qu'elle écrit les us badinter elle dit
voilà il ya une contre société qui est
en train de s'ériger insidieusement et
elle a une visée le préparatifs pouvoir
sécessionnistes le voile c'est une
opinion le port du voile pour je pense
que le peuple tu vois c'est un insigne
politico religieux absolument
l' islam radical et on a d'un islam
radical qui veut imposer ses règles et
nous on veut lutter mais sans eux vous
aller plus loin mais on n'a pas joué les
deux de dire dans la rue de marcher dans
la rue ou en disant je suis musulman
mais bien sûr mais c'est pas le problème
on peut bien se balader avec afficheur
l'épreuve la pma ou vive la manif est
retour bien sûr mais bien sûr mais vous
mélangez touché d'argent je sais ce que
je vois d'air ça me fait sourire rien
que ça ça me détend je veux simplement
dire c'est que on a affaire en france un
double phénomène il ya le djihadisme qui
tue il a tué à la préfecture de paris
récemment encore ce djihadisme
djihadisme qui tue la préfecture de
police et le port du voile par une
faveur à fait le lien entre le
djihadisme et la radicalisation de
l'islam
la radicalisation de l'islam sous par
exemple et mener des frères musulmans
des salafistes qui conquiert des
quartiers hanté entier et c'est le
terreau dans lequel est que vont éclore
demain justement l'évocation de fusil
futur jet
les choses sont très claires il ya un
phénomène sanglant est un phénomène
souterrain mais négligé le phénomène
soutient ne pas lui signifier qu' on a
parfaitement compris ce qu'il souhaite
faire et que on ne posera pas de limite
si on abandonne tout si on renonce
jean tendre les commentateurs depuis
quelques jours que ce soit sur le voile
dans les sorties scolaires ou sur ma
proposition de loi rien ne serait
possible de faire on abdique il ferait
que la république abdique les principes
récital commentateurs n'ont pas tous
sont non non non mais les dés qu'on
pourrait l'espérer j'ai alors puis je
vais passer à autre chose parce qu'il ya
d'autres sujets d'actualité peut-on
porter le foulard ou le voile et
pratique un islam modéré
moi je pense que je pense franchement
que toutes les femmes qui portent le
voile ou le full ne sont pas nouveaux le
foulard oui vous avez les mots aussi
j'aime les ne sont pas nécessairement
des islamistes en revanche tous les
islamistes
tous les islamistes exigent des femmes
qu'elles portent le voile et c'est ça
qui est compliqué et c'est pour ça qu'on
doit nous poser des limites c'est limite
s sont strictes et la main républicaine
ne doit pas trembler les républicains de
la rive droite et de la rive gauche
doivent se tendre la main bien bruno
retailleau la sncf l'a vu ce qui s'est
passé à la sncf ce qu'il faut suspendre
la conduite des trains par un agent seul
à bord je parle des trains régionaux
notamment ça vous concerne
oui ça me concerne non mais non je ne
pense que ce qui s'est passé je pense
que ce qui s'est passé c'est un
détournement du droit de retrait c'est
tout un détournement du droit
cela vous rejoignez nous sommes entrés
oui ça m'arrive bonne chose ça n'est pas
parce que c'est le gouvernement auquel
je m'oppose le plus généralement je
pense qu'il a raison et je pense que
certains syndicats font de ce droit de
retrait une sorte de hors d'oeuvre pour
la manifestation du du 5 décembre c'est
une sorte d'échauffement en
l'échauffement vous soutenez cette
réforme des retraites
non non d'abord c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui
oui à en voir les détours plus avoir
moins on comprend
et quand il ya du vent d'autres corps
voilà mais croyez-moi je pense que cette
réforme les français seront déçus parce
que pour beaucoup il perd en plus
touché - vous allez rejoindre les
manifestants du cndd essor je voulais
déjà dit je suis législateur donc j'ai
un moyen d'exprimer donc fraîcheur aussi
j'ai vu regarder pour les familles
républicains voulaient tourner le départ
louis par la taille à 68 ans à 155 parle
oui enfin 65 ans officiellement me donne
j'ai été un des premiers gta des pros
mais je pensais je crois que c'était à
votre micro d'ailleurs quand certains de
mes amis voulaient mettre les choses
sous le tapis j'étais de toute façon
comme monsieur mitterrand a porté la
retraite de 65 à 60 60 ans il avait 74
ans de dur et d'espérance de vie
aujourd'hui on a 83 ans
donc évidemment le problème des mails
macron pourquoi ce qui est mal macron à
taper les retraités pourquoi est-ce
qu'il a désindexé les retraites parce
qu'il avait fait une promesse de ne pas
augmenter l'âge légal de départ en
retraite de plus de 62 ans messiah pas
de et pas de secret et moi je le dis aux
retraités qui m'écoutent à tous les
français de demain qui seront concernés
si on allonge pas la durée de travail et
l'âge légal de départ en retraite
vous toucherez - et il ira en changer
les rideaux m3 du tout un système à
points mais le système à points
c'est de la mécanique l'important
aujourd'hui puisque déjà le système on
n'attendra pas 2025
j'attends du gouvernement que très
rapidement puisque les comptes sont
désormais dans le rouge
on nous avait vanté que ma et macro
rétablirait bouche le trou de la
sécurité sociale c'est faux donc il faut
que le gouvernement agisse très vite
maintenant de savoir s'il faut un régime
unique moi je pense qu'on arrivera pas
un régime unique je pense qu'il faudrait
sans doute la bonne réforme
c'est un socle de base pour les
fonctionnaires pour le privé et pour les
sans doute les libéraux les indépendants
avec des retraites complémentaires pour
permettre au lieu de 42
je pense que à trois régimes on arrive
parce que des spécificités c'est tout et
que on a l'esprit français et vous avez
des technocrates français qui veulent
dessiner un jardin à la française que
l'on soit tous les mêmes et on n'est pas
tous les mêmes on a parfois des
carrières un peu différente la syrie
j'ai vu
votre demande de forte demande vous
demander à l'union européenne d'agir il
agir face à l'offensive turque
mais pardon mais que peut faire l'europe
ont beaucoup et c'est à dire on peut
faire beaucoup le remplacer les
américains sur le terrain non c'est
parce que je n'en rend on peut enfin
suspendre définitivement les pourparlers
d'adhésion de la turquie à l'europe mots
ça fait 20 ans que je me bats pour dire
que la turquie ne sera jamais dans
l'union européenne c'est une évidence
95 % de son territoire et cet essai oui
parmi les discussions sur l'adhésion
sont tellement bien suspendu de l'ue est
non non non et celle ci officiellement
non même si vous avez des crédits qui
sont votées au parlement européen
justement pour ce genre de choses dont
on arrête pml macro aurait dû rappeler
notre ambassadeur à ankara
bien sûr mais bien sûr bien sûr qu'il
est on aurait dû pourquoi est-ce que
lorsque monsieur poutine dit moi on est
bien content jarre d'or dont je vais pas
défendre la turquie on est bien content
de voir les turcs accueillir 3 million
et demi de réfugiés syriens qu'on veut
pas nous que vous ne voulez pas mais on
est content qu'un homme politique
français ne veut et quand la turquie
et quand la turquie finance l état
islamique en laissant passer les bidons
de pétrole sur son territoire et quand
la turquie permettait aux djihadistes de
passer par sa frontière pour aller
renforcer des ch
on en était content de l'accord mais si
on ne peut pas supporter membres de la
coalition rendez compte c'est vraiment
scandaleux comme la décision de monsieur
trump est scandaleux moi je pense que
depuis longtemps depuis longtemps la
france s'est totalement alignée derrière
monsieur obama derrière monsieur trump
nous nous sommes alignés nous avons
perdu notre position d'équilibré au
droit par dénoncer effectivement
suspendre ses discussions avec la
turquie et bien livré par exemple du
mythe du matériel militaire aux kurdes
évidemment on n'est pas des enfants de
choeur et il ya la diplomatie la
diplomatie c'est important faire le sale
boulot qu aux kurdes mais on l'attendait
c'est terrible on est en train
d'abandonner les kurdes et c'est
l'écurie qui font le sale boulot pour
nous mais non mais c'est ça qui était
une entaille au juste
c'est la vérité vous savez que jaca
n'aurait jamais été reprise par les
forces démocratiques syriennes ya
quelques jours vous êtes une kurde mais
je suis on n'avait pas les coeurs on ne
doit pas les abandonner et moi je je
lutte mais là aussi un bon niveau donc
c'est le parlement c'est le gouvernement
que j'essaie d'influencé pour dire
attention poser une limite parce que
avec des gens comme monsieur erdogan
on ne sait jamais où ils vont s'arrêter
fin le miam le maître du jeu vous le
connaissez et c'est monsieur poutine
c'est monsieur coûté la vie à justement
et bien justement ça fait depuis des
années que je demande à la france de
reprendre un dialogue avec la russie
parce que les états unis je les
encourage et absolument cette fait
effectivement il faut régler quelques
problèmes notamment avec l'ukraine
et puis la grille mais mais je pense que
c'est une bonne chose je pense que la
russie a intérêt de se rapprocher de
l'europe plutôt que de la chine
voilà et je pense que la france a
intérêt de retrouver sa position
d'équilibré entre les états unis et la
russie
pas d'alignement et c'est parce que on
sait aligner qu'on a été totalement
marginalisée sur la scène notamment
syrienne bruno retailleau
j'ai lu françois hollande qui demande
que le cac soit transformé en sextennat
six ans qu'en pensez vous assaisonnement
et d'envié c'est vraiment à étudier je
vous dis pourquoi je veux pas me
prononcer en gênant menace a récemment
non je vais vous dire pourquoi moi je
considère que qu'est ce qu'une
démocratie et c'est deux choses une
démocratie c'est le suffrage universel
mais pas seulement parce que monsieur
erdogan serait sinon un grand démocrate
bah oui donc il faut une deuxième
condition il faut la séparation des
pouvoirs notamment entre l'exécutif le
président et puis le premier ministre
et puis aussi le parlement or depuis
qu'il ya le quinquennat mais surtout
depuis qu'ils à l'inversion du
calendrier
les députés sont le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle
ils ne sont que le sous produit si j'ose
dire pardonnez moi pour mes amis députés
mais c'est la réplique sismique les
législatives
et donc je pense que décaler les
élections ça permettrait d'avoir plus
d'indépendance entre l'élection
présidentielle et l'élection législative
et on retrouverait sans doute une
meilleure capacité
à séparer les pouvoirs entre l'assemblée
nationale qui est trop souvent le petit
doigt sur la couture du pantalon et je
pense que ça c'est pas le fait d'une
grande démocratie
alors ça sert le sénat actuellement mme
chénel joue le rôle d' équilibre assez
louche les écarter toute candidature à
la présidentielle
mais j'avoue que j'ai déjà répondu à une
question que je sais que ça pointent à
l'horizon
j'ai répondu que si mes convictions sont
portés ya pas besoin blême je me
rallierai serre sont pas portés je
m'interrogerais oui je suis constant les
cmi et vous l'êtes avec moi aussi
d'ailleurs
merci bruno il est un si joli mot vin